good evening
uh everybody i am uh very delighted
uh to see you uh all for joining for
this exciting event
um i'm so glad to see so many of you are
joining us tonight on zoom
um we wish we could have been in person
i'm here at
the yale quantum institute uh on this
very empty auditorium
but soon enough we'll we'll have you
over
so for those who don't know me my name
is florian carl i am the manager of the
yale quantum institute
and the curator of this series of
non-technical talks are co-sponsored by
the frankie program for science and the
humanities
the goal of these events is to bring a
new regard
on quantum physics and science in
general by having experts
cast a new look on an often overlooked
aspect of scientific work
this is our 11th event and this month
marked the four-year anniversary of this
series that started in
2017. during this four year we explored
a variation of topics
from music to quantum physics math and
crochet
space exploration and board games
biology and cloning
and tonight we have the chance to
welcome the uh aclam author and poet
ben ocry for a special evening on
quantum physics and fiction
let me introduce the speaker for tonight
um so
benecrete was born in mina nigeria his
childhood was divided between nigeria
where he
so firsthand the consequences of war and
london
he won the booker prize in 1991 for
the famish roads and his novel the
astronautish the astonishing of gods
was selected as bbc number 100
bbc's hundred novel that chapter world
his work has been translated into more
than 25 languages
and he also write plays on screenplay
he's a fellow of the royal
society of literature and has been
awarded the prestigious order of british
empire as well as numerous international
prizes
and honorary dictor rates he's out
tonight for
his pregnancy his newest book prayer for
the living who was released
which was released earlier this month in
the us i do have the the uk version
uh the u.s version has the cover that
you have behind me
uh it's a collection of short story uh
that includes alternative realities
for the live action disability are true
which is going to read tonight it's a
strange investigation of a murder in
london
and you'll see very quickly that it
follows the strange pattern
of quantum physics so this event is
going to be split in two parts uh then
we'll read the story uh and we'll have
a slideshow that goes along with it and
then after the story
um we'll have a q a and without further
please welcome ben
and uh feel free to start whenever you
want
well florian um it's uh it's a
a real pleasure um
to be there um and here
um it's uh almost uh in itself uh a
quantum situation that one is
um in two places at the same time
um and
tonight i'll be reading alternative
realities are true
which is uh set in london and various
verses um or shall i say
universes multiverses i must also add
that it's a real pleasure
that you're all here and i thank you
very much be great in the flesh but you
know when all this is over
let's hope we can manage it
alternative realities are true
it begins with a quotation
how wonderful that we have met with a
paradox
now we have some hope of making progress
neos bowl
he woke one morning into a strange
universe
everything in his one bedroom flat in
cancer rise
was exactly the same but everything was
also
subtly different he was not sure
how there was a message for him on the
answering machine
which he listened to with the irritation
the acute heat
brought him he hadn't been able to sleep
he had been puzzling over his latest
case
with each new piece of information he
was finding it more troubling
the message was from the office
delivered in a verbal encryption which
he
simultaneously deciphered
the dead man had been seen in the cafe
at the canal
he looked through the crack in his
curtains
it was nearly dawn in his garden
the black birds whistled their morning
corals
usually when he heard them he knew that
sleep was
over for him this morning
there was something different about
their tone
detective draper got out of bed
and slipped on his dressing gown and
went to his study to review the case
on the face of it the case was simple
there had been a murder near him in
council rise
but the body of the victim had not been
found
there was no actual proof of murder but
there was
knowledge of it a young
overwrought muslim woman in a blue
hairdress who gave her name as anna
had come into the local police station
she had broken down and said a man she
knew had been murdered
she gave his name when asked how she
knew he had been murdered
her eyes widened and she threw up her
hands
she knew she said who was the murdered
man
who was he to her she was asked
but she would not say who was the killer
she was asked at this she panicked
and fled from the station a few
inquiries led them to her address
and a watch was placed on the building
a man by the name of barrett the
assistant of a famous artist went
missing
that same day he had been known to
frequent the woman's flat this was a
month ago
barrett had still not been found
detective draper who believed more than
anything that intuition was superior to
intellectual deduction opposing himself
to the theatrical methods
of sherlock holmes which had so
captivated the police force
scotland yard and the general public
knew that he was dealing with a case
that amounted to
more than the appearance of the facts he
believed
that he was indeed he believed that it
was indeed essential to study a case
thoroughly to acquaint oneself with the
locale of the crime
to handle the items of the principal
players
in short to furnish the senses and
instinct
with all the available data and living
facts possible
and then like a fisherman who must
commit himself to the sea
he must leave all those facts behind and
trust
to the mysterious dictates of intuition
he had developed the faculty of
intuition as a young man when he trained
himself to be able to tell
on which side a coin would fall just by
following
the clearest whisper in his head by slow
degrees
applying this method to phone calls
knocks on doors
letters that he had received guessing
their contents and who had sent them
before
opening them for verification he had
come to develop this mysterious faculty
to a formidable degree
detective draper never spoke about this
to anybody
knowing full well he would be a laugh in
stock
if he did he masked his secret technique
behind a tremendous amount of paperwork
and planning and detailed analysis
to all accounts from the outside he was
an eminently practical detective
who did his research and left nothing to
chance
in truth he believed in the fertility of
chance itself
which he did not regard as chance at all
he believed
that all things in the universe were
linked and that
every fact was related to every other
from his armchair he solved his cases by
indirection
he was the best in the force his
reputation
unmatched
that morning in his study he went over
the case
methodically he realized that there was
something
wrong with the facts of the case some
slight
alteration of the world for example
as soon as they put a watch in the
muslim woman's house certain other facts
of the case shifted this was puzzling
the watch reported that through the
window
he had seen anna's neighbor a man named
yog
cutting up a large chicken
the moment he noticed the chicken being
caught up the lights in
anna's room had come on
here was where it became baffling the
watch swore
that he saw yog both cutting up the
chicken
and going into anna's room at the same
time
the watch was a sober man of
unimpeachable
reputation there were several
other curious anomalies
another taken at random was that when
york was seen cutting up the large
chicken in his room
the reported victim of the murder was
seen by witnesses
in a cafe on the canal a few miles down
the road
those who saw him said that he looked
well
if a bit anxious that he was written a
book at the time
most of the witnesses could not recall
the title of the book
detective draper did not think this at
all unusual
most people he found did not notice what
was
right under their noses the
inattentiveness of people
was a constant source of amusement to
him
he had come to rely on their failure to
notice things his best deductions
came from working round the bends of
this
failure questioning one of the
witnesses he was able through
indirection to work out the title of the
book
to any other detective such a detail as
a title of a book
a victim was reading would be
insignificant but to detective draper
nothing in the universe was
insignificant
the witness remembered the fact that the
victim
was reading a cat
what do you mean he was reading a cat
he was reading a cat did he have an
actual cat in his hand
both hands what color was
the cat it did not have
a color did it have a name
the last question had come to detective
draper purely by intuition
it had simply dropped into his mind like
that
but behind the intuition hovering like
the ghost of knowledge
was the understanding that some people
see words
as real things and that they are
incapable of the abstract faculty
of reading transferring everything they
read that has an
image straight away into its physical
equivalent
this was one of those anomalous facts
that the detective stored away
in his mind yes it did have a name
what was it it was a very strange name
before you tell me what it was tell me
how you knew
it's strange but i just did i looked at
the cat it was reading
and its name popped into my head just
like that
there is no need to tell me the name of
the cat the detective the
the detective said nonchalantly
why not i know it already but thank you
the detective rose to signify the end of
the interview leaving the witness
quite baffled detective draper
as absent-minded the moment he was
consumed by a clue
called several bookshops in a short time
he found out what he wanted to know
a copy of the book had been purchased
that day quite early in the morning
from any amount of books on charing
cross road
it was the only copy of the book
purchased that morning
a check confirmed that the book had been
bought by a yog
as the detective had suspected
another call to the local police station
confirmed something else
that the victim had not been seen since
as it stood there were two sightings
one was of the suspected killer
in two places at the same time
the other was of the victim after he had
gone missing
and was presumed dead
for the rest of the day contradictory
reports kept pouring in
a warrant for the arrest of yogg led to
his detention
the large chicken he had been seen
cutting up was brought in
as evidence but that same evening
yog who was in police custody
was seen in anna's room
he was shouting at her and at one point
called her a [ __ ]
i have killed that lover of yours and
there's nothing anyone can do about it
he said what have you done to him she
cried
i have hidden him where no one will ever
be able to find him
he was heard wailing and yog was seen
departing
from the room the watch was unable to do
anything
because he had conclusive proof that the
murder suspect
was in police custody he had no legal
right
to arrest the same person twice
detective draper considered the arrest
of yog to have been
an act of sublime stupidity by the local
police
the detective dropped in at the local
station
the sergeant on duty a thick set man was
reading
may gray his name was pillock
and he had and he had reputation for
bruce ness
the way i see it detective he said is
that we know a crime has been committed
but we have no evidence
we suspect it's a murder but there is no
body
and he could be a potential terrorist we
have to keep him locked up for the
public good
the detective contemplated sergeant
pilock
there was no use arguing with him
explanation was equally futile
he would have to add the heavy
footedness of the sergeant
into the equation but do you see that
the problem multiplies
draper said i see that it simplifies
any new evidence only cctv footage on a
boss
what number six is that significant
everything is significant draper said
what did the footage yield
something puzzling what
the suspect made several trips in one
direction with black plastic bags
he appeared to be moving house we never
saw him get off
anything else yes but it doesn't make
sense
tell me it stretches credibility
let's have it on one of the cameras we
caught an image of the bus
just as it exploded did it explode
that's just it it didn't we believe the
cctv system has been hacked
and false footage has been planted there
unless there is an equally radical
solution
but i fear we may be too late we have to
act fast
what shall we do the detective did a
rapid calculation he felt himself
circled by time the first thing he did
was order that the watch be
pulled off anna's house then he
suggested that the suspect
be released and not followed not
followed
no but it must be followed
it will only make things worse how
we are being invaded by one
of many possible futures draper said
what was that nothing forget it are you
on something
no i'm sober as a surgeon on duty
well then you need to fill me in
detective draper knew he could not
explain the intuition that was filtering
through to him wearily he sought the
most
innocuous expression of it he softened
his voice as he spoke
everything we do influences what the
suspect does
we are multiplying the problem before
there was one murderer now
there are three three
which three three
the detective corrected himself i meant
he should be free
two
detective draper knew there were only
two ways to resolve the case
one was to prevent the murder the other
was to uncover it all the evidence
suggested it was too late
to prevent the murder it had happened
the past had now been lost
if the victim had been apprehended when
he was seen reading the cat
things might have been different that
moment was gone
it was lost because no one noticed that
the past
lurks in the present not just past
events
but the past as present
detective draper liked to walk after he
had been
immersed in facts too long
when he had spent all day reading
documents studying evidence listening to
witnesses
when he was saturated with too much
information
he would walk in a zigzag path through
side streets
to his home anyone seeing him would
think he was
wondering aimlessly but his works always
followed
the pattern of his thoughts
he had always known that the indirect
route
led more quickly to his destination
the direct routes were often bogged down
in interruptions
conversations and crowded streets
that evening after a long spell at the
station he left late
his thoughts had gone off the map of
indirection
he had taken so many side streets that
he did not recognize where he was
he didn't mind his best intuitions came
while he was walking and while
waking or rather his best intuitions
came while
waking and while walking
in an odd way he seemed to be doing both
now
he seemed to be waking from the sleep of
his thoughts
where was he he looked around
he had gone off the main road that led
to his flat and cancel rise
the street where he now stood looked
decidedly strange
he searched for the street name and
found that he did not even recognize
that
he walked on till he came to a barber
shop there were no customers
when he went in he started the barber
who was reading the newspaper
can you please tell me where i am the
barber stared at him with his mouth half
open
is anything wrong you came in here about
five minutes ago
the baba said and you asked the very
same question detective draper looked
around at the clock on the wall
with his roman numerals it was 6 35
pm so i did
so i did detective draper muhammad
and he hurried out he went back the way
he had come
a glance told him that the baba had come
out of this as
come out of his shop and was watching
him
he walked faster away that the faster he
walked
the faster walked all the events
connected to him
if he sped up things would speed up too
the web of connected events responded to
his every
deed suddenly in his mind he could see
the lines
that linked him to the victim and the
murderer
and the woman except that these lines
had multiplied in ways he could only
guess at
he was walking aimlessly now following
the vectors of his thoughts he
conjectured that
if he had arrived at this strange place
by getting lost
then only by getting lost again could he
return to a familiar world
he was thinking fast and walking fast as
if something unknown were
stuck in him the lincoln lines moved
faster in his mind
then he suddenly stopped
in the middle of all that wandering a
clear thought distilled and
pristine dropped into his mind
why hadn't he thought of that before
there was now only one way to serve the
matter
the past was close to him there was only
one path left
he had to arrive at a future place
before the murderer did
he had to outwit him in all the vectors
of time at this point
the murderer had a time advantage over
him
he had to overturn that advantage he had
to anticipate the murderer
in the future he walked home much more
slowly
he noticed the council estates and the
silver birches
and the uneven pavement
it did not surprise him that he now knew
where he was
he walked slowly and breathed evenly
as he turned into a street someone
brushed past him
the detective caught a confident smile
on the face of the man who had jostled
him
he was at his front gate when he
realized that the smile belonged
to the murder suspect but when he turned
to look
the man was gone there was an envelope
pinned to his front door inside the
envelope
was a message composed of letters cut
out of newspapers and
magazines the message read
all alternative realities are true
the detective let himself into his flat
shut the door
behind him and pour himself a glass of
argentinian
altamira he sat down at a table near a
window to contemplate the letter
after a while he brought out a worn book
of escher drawings leaving the door in
his mind open
he contemplated the drawings but in the
other rooms in his mind
he was thinking
in his research he had discovered
that the murder suspect had an unusual
interest in a branch of speculative
physics
in one room in his mind he realized that
the solution to the crime was not to be
found
in the real world but in an unreal space
a speculative realm
in another room he pondered the message
he had received
all alternative realities are true
he contemplated the ramifications of the
message while leafing through the
drawings
calmly he began to chart out the clear
lines
of the case soon he came to a dead end
he paused and put down the book
he knew that all dead ends are
an illusion designed to bring motion to
a halt
to those who can see beyond the illusion
dead ends are portals into unknown
possibilities
he paid more attention to dead ends
than to open highways
he knew now that a leap of faith was
required
then you remember the cat that both men
had
then he remembered the cat that was both
seen
and not seen he realized he was going to
have to work backward
he wanted to he went to sleep that night
with the feeling that he had at least
stopped the multiplication of the
problem
part three the next morning
an envelope was posted through his
letterbox
before he opened it he knew that he
would find
letters cut out of newspapers and
magazines composing
an elusive message the envelope
contained
a single sheet of white paper with the
words
the world is still here
he had a shower got dressed regarded his
face
in the mirror the mirror had a slight
warp that morning he was not sure
that the world was still there
outside the weather had changed
the sun shone intermittently
through the dark masses of clouds a cool
wind
with a deceptively icy core blew from
the south
he went down the side streets towards
the cafe where the victim
barrett had been seen reading a cat
the cafe was run by a long-haired
italian who combined
obsequiousness with a mildly intrusive
personal charm sitting in the same seat
where the victim had been seen within a
cat detective draper
saw the canal beyond the balcony
there were boats moored on both sides
the detective drank his hot water slowly
he had given up drinking coffee years
ago
and now settled for the digestive
digestive refinements
of hot water outside birds were wheeling
over the canal
while sipping he had a singular thought
he knew that entertaining it would
create realities that
would only blur the case further so he
pushed the thought to a
corner of his mind he caught a taxi back
to the office
to test his theory he had his contact in
the at the evening standard
planned a report that the police were
draining an obscure canal
in richmond in their search for the
missing body
to lend this deception the veneer of
plausibility
he had two amateur frog men busily
explore the canal they were to pretend
to pull something out of its shallow
depths
what's the idea behind this flagrant
waste of public funds
on sham frogmen in a remote canal asked
his
superintendent who had summoned him to
lunch
you're aware that i have gone out on a
limb for you too many times
and i have never let you down have i
detective draper replied calmly
butchering his role
no you haven't i grant that but there
are many people after your job
they will use anything to get at you god
knows you have enough disadvantages as
it is
do i detective draper said while the
glimmer of a new thought
filtered through a door in his mind you
know you do
you're not an oxbridge man neither are
you
you are black i wasn't going to say that
but you thought it look we run the most
colorblind department in the country you
took the words right out of my mouth
but i'm the only one that is we have to
face the realities of the world
detective drake was suddenly stiffened
he held his head
at an angle a new thought had come
through
do we he said absent-mindedly
yes we do reply the superintendent
puzzled by draper's behavior
have you had this conversation with me
before
that's what i was getting to about an
hour ago
yes why we don't have any time
we have to stop it now stop what
there will be another murder unless we
act fast
murder of who the woman
she'll be murdered and there'll be no
evidence of it
why not because she would have been
murdered yesterday
detective draper stood up you're not
making sense
man the superintendent exploded sit down
and explain yourselves
i really must dash sir i'll have a full
explanation for you
tomorrow afternoon if all goes well but
tomorrow is sunday
but tomorrow is saturday the
superintendent said
to the departing figure of the detective
yorkshire are playing middlesex
at the oval i know draper said
before he disappeared through the door
and the score will be 17 to 1.
what cried the superintendent
detective draper was already out on the
street
part four from the council rise
police station detective draper
requisitioned
three frog men early on saturday morning
he had them dive into the canal at
little venice
right near the cafe the area was
cordoned off
the frogmen in their dark wetsuits
began their mysterious exploration
there was a unit of police there with an
unmistakable police van
detective dripper watched from a
distance
if his intuition was correct in the next
hour
a number of things would happen their
precise order
interested him he knew he was
in the realm of a speculative space now
where
actually seeing what was sought made
its existence real
the time the opportunity were limited
things were in mutant formation
events were hovering between two realms
between
being and non-being from here on
the operation would be delicate the
frogmen
in the obscure canal at richmond found
nothing as was the intention
but the story planted in the evening
standard had its desired effect
as far as a detective could tell
he kept looking at his watch the frogmen
here at the little venice canal
took turns in going in
one of them would stand on the edge of
the canal and then flip over
backwards he would root around below for
a while
and then emerge for now
now they had been exploring and had
found nothing
the cricket game had begun at the oval
the heat was beginning to rise it was a
bright day and people
had begun to stop to watch the strange
proceedings on the canal these two
had been factored into detective
draper's complex calculation
of events only by the frogmen diving
verifying and bringing up could there be
anything to
dive for verify and bring up
the detective knew this something will
be found
only because something is looked for
the looking creates the finding
in just the same way only the presence
of onlookers
created the event the answers were
essential
the detective had surmised that what was
needed was a
waiting of events a weigh-in of events
toward a
more dense reality to counter-balance
the ambiguous
reality between walls which had so far
bedevilled
the investigation he intuited
that all worlds had to come together
here
that was why even before he had full
permission
it arranged for the frogmen to make a
public exhibition
of excavating excavating the muddy
depths
of the canal the ruse had worked
the item planted in the evening standard
had caught the lively interest of
londoners
and soon everyone was talking about it
the crowds around the canal observing
the frogmen
grew in number the trap sprung
had yielded multi-dimensional fruit
an off-duty policeman had spotted the
suspected murderer
near the little venice canal and had
reported the matter
to the local police station the station
chief had relayed the message
to detective draper with a nonchalant
exploration
he continued to observe the frogmen at
work
twice the frogman claims to have found
nothing
they said they had said it was just mud
and rotten bicycles
and broken paddles down there
the detective with his keen awareness of
the power of numbers
said twice does not make anything
conclusive
they can now conceal secrets which must
be exposed
my career depends on it maybe even my
life
you send the frogmen down a third time
he suggested that they look not so much
in the deeper parts
but in the parts no one would think of
looking
what part is that sir one of the frogmen
said
you will know when you find it
disgruntled they returned to work
they flipped over backward and
disappeared beneath the mudded
surface detective draper
aware of the proximity of the murderer
knew that he
knew that it was now a race against time
the frogman had to find something before
the murderer
found him he remained calm
he ordered a cup of hot water from the
cafe
the cafe manager the insouciant italian
brought the water himself his disheveled
locks fell across his face
the italian handed the detective the cup
of hot water
and held onto the pot so what is going
on sir
the cafe manager asked detective draper
turned to look at him
the italian had the eyes of an insomniac
it's best if you don't know we don't
want you entangled
in the multiple webs of the problem
you might be able to help how
i hear things people tell me things
i'm sure that's true i'll contact you if
your help is required
any time said the italian it would be an
honor to be of service
the cafe manager stood there watching
the first frogman
emerge from the murky canal
the detective turned to him with a
furrowed brow and the italian
immediately
understood that his presence had become
redundant he filled
the detective's cup and retreated into
his cafe
detective draper felt the murderer
moving closer
but he sipped his hot water with perfect
carn
it's not the number of encounters in the
numberless realms that count
it is the world in which the encounter
is fixed
thought the detective grimly
a flurry among the frogmen told him that
the nature of the game had shifted at
last
he drank what was left of his hot water
and went toward them
one of the frogmen had pulled out from
the depths of the canal a black
plastic bag dripping with muck
it was placed on the ground the frogman
hosed it down and then detect and then
the detective had it brought to the back
of the van
a casual glance at its form told him
what he needed to know
there was no need to expose the contents
the first stage of the duo had been
fought
it might have been difficult to fix the
reality of this black dustbin bag
but now that it was fixed the rest was
sure to be found
it was at that moment perhaps delayed
by the variable factors in the
calculations of time
that the shadow moved into sight
jorg fired two shots one pierced the
metal of the white van the other
grazed detective draper's shoulder
then jorg was wrestled to the ground by
the plainclothes policeman
who had been drinking cups of innocuous
tea
in the cafe before the detective fell
he was hurt to cry out on no account are
the frogmen to cease the exploration
he passed out for only a few moments
an act of will wrenched him back into
consciousness
detective draper allowed the paramedics
to bandage his shoulder
while he surveyed the scene before him
the frogmen had persisted and eventually
they had dredged up
three black bin liners from diverse
parts of the canal
they were hosed down and kept in the
back of the van but the bullet
had pierced the detective
had no need to inspect their contents he
knew
what they were the afternoon sun
played on the water of the canal making
its surface
shine like gun metal the light came
through the trees on both sides of the
metal fences
detective draper could see the church
through the leaves
he felt tired he made a signal to one of
the men
they bore him to a waiting car but
instead of being taken to the hospital
for further treatment
he insisted on being taken home
section five
the next morning with his arm in a sling
detective draper was at the police
station out of respect for the part
he had played in the investigation he
was allowed the first conference with
the man who had shot him
they were in a soundproof room the
detective sat in a chair
at the table and the murderess that
opposite
something puzzles me said yog there was
nothing repentant about his expression
he stared
at the detective intensely
you want to know how i knew where to
look
york smiled it was a thin smile
sustained by something resembling a
twitch
then he nodded faintly
my question to you said draper
is why why what
they were still dueling it was not over
yet
there was still the chance of further
multiplications
he had to be careful why did you kill
him
are you sure it is why and not when
i know when you do
you're not going to trap me that easily
again
i have no idea what you mean of course
you do
said draper all alternative rarities are
true
i see said york you got the clue
it was designed to throw me off the
scent
you went against your own psychology
said york
like you i have many psychologists the
detective said leaning back
but why did you kill him he was after my
woman
she was not your woman she told the
police that
you were just her neighbor and that you
misunderstood her friendship
she was a [ __ ] and she and she and he
deserved to die
he's not even he was not even one of us
you killed him out of jealousy not
jealousy
revenge the detective stood up
he felt weary he was at the door when
york
fired the last question at him how did
you know
the detective at that moment felt a
throb of pain in his shoulder
the world is still here he replied
went out section six
three hours later he was sitting with
the superintendent
in the scotland the yard can team they
had window seats looking out over the
river
the facts don't make sense can you make
sense of them for me so i can explain it
to the board
i don't recommend an explanation what
then
leave them with the facts sometimes
people need to be brought face to face
with the
incomprehensibility of the world
the superintendent stared at him
now you know why you will never make
department head
he said it was never my ambition you
have ambitions
i have ambitions that perhaps you won't
understand
said the detective sipping his hot water
besides there are things better than
ambition
how can you stand to drink that
tasteless stuff
it's not tasteless at all draper said it
restores to me
it restores me to the fundamental
simplicity of the world
the world seems to be anything but
simple take this case for example
what on earth was going on
it wouldn't make sense if i explained it
try me
it was a multiverse murder what on earth
is that speak plain english man
it was a murder that happened in many
universes
you must be mad in one universe
the murder hadn't happened yet in
another
it had each time we apprehended him
we multiplied okay that's enough of that
if i hear any more
i might start to have crackpot ideas
myself just tell me this
why the canal i realized
i realized it when i learned the victim
was seen
in the cafe reading a cat reading a cat
the policeman who saw him was dyslexic
his condition was extreme he virtually
he saw
virtually what he read about one percent
of dyslexics have this syndrome
what was the cat he was reading it was a
book
the book gave me the second clue the
rest unraveled itself
out with it man you're tied me up in
riddles what was the book
schrodinger's cat schrodinger's what
he had bought the book that morning and
was seen reading it
in the cafe after he had been murdered
unless we are dealing with apparitions
there could be only one solution
the superintendent looked red-faced and
exasperated
i had to somehow get all the universes
in which the murder was multiplying
to converge i had to create what
physicists called
an event convergence what on earth is
that
valued the superintendent by now a
swollen
image of himself it is the one event the
one
thing that will fix time in quantum
mechanics it is conjecture that the
universe
only comes into existence when we
perceive it
i surmise that perhaps the body of the
victim would only be found
when we find it the crime did not exist
till the body was found
and the body was in the bin bags exactly
how did you know one of them
one of the watchers outside women's
house had seen the murderer murder
suspect cutting up a chicken
it was a chicken it was a chicken
because the watcher had seen a
do you mean to say yes
the superintendent paused for a long
moment
but why was he trying to kill you
he wasn't really we have to understand
that
this man was taking a cosmic gamble
he never really had any intention of
killing anybody
he was overcome with rage with jealousy
with a kind of love madness
in that state it declared to him that
maybe if he killed a man in one universe
the man would still be alive in another
somewhere along the line he forgot what
universe he was in
in short he lost his reason you you mean
he went mad
depends on what you think madness is
continue
in one of those universes it occurred to
him that if he
could stop me before i could find the
body
then he would never be caught and the
murder
would to all accounts be forever
speculative
why wasn't i told all this at the time
you were at your cricket match sir a
terrible game
we were mauled sorry to hear that sir
still you could have sent a message it
was a delicate matter
what does that mean i had to arrive at
the body before the bullet
arrived in me there was a long pause
detective draper you look terrible you
super tender and said
when was the last time you had some sun
i can't remember sir
get some sun i want that shoulder i want
that shoulder working when you get back
take a holiday detective draper
thank you sir the detective said with
the right smile
i think i might while the world is
still here
that was a fantastic story thank you so
much for taking the time to um to relate
to us
it was a pleasure it's a pleasure much
more fun than i
feared it would be um we're having
a bunch of people in the q and a
starting question question and things
but the first thing that i want to ask
you is that there's
there's very few literary works about
quantum physics
the one that comes in mind is the the
michael phrase play
copenhagen that staged the discussion
between
uh neil bose which used as an epigraph
for your story
and heisenberg and ex-wife noland but
murder in quantum physics is kind of a
unique mix like
can you tell us a little bit why you
choose quantum physics to stage this at
this mother and how did it explode
together or like what's what was your
process
what it's very hard to talk of process
with a with a story like this
um um if i i don't know if i should tell
you how the story came about it might
actually spoil the wonderful mystery of
it
let's just let's just say very simply
that um
um i was put in a position where i had
to write a
a a story a detective story
and uh you know i've read so many
detective stories and i thought
i thought to myself i don't i really
don't know how i can add anything to
this uh
to this really famous uh genre
and uh at the same time for some time in
fact for a long time i've been
i've been i've been having a very secret
interest in quantum physics and quantum
mechanics and i've been reading
around the edges of it for all sorts of
reasons uh partly because of fascination
with this with this field and this
subject because it's one of the
one of the few fields in in in science
uh that for the first time actually
begins to undermine the certainties that
we have about reality
um and also one of the fields in science
that for the first time begins to hint
at uh as a kind of a spectral
unseen and fascinating dimension to
existence
and to the world as we think we know it
um it's in fact it's this is an area
that really troubles
the surface of our certainties and i i
found that really really really magnetic
um so i i i i thought to myself
wouldn't it be wonderful if i brought um
a great secret love
with um a public
uh problem um you know i had to have to
write a detective story
and wouldn't it be great if i brought
the two things together so
i conceived of the idea of detective
draper and
um that the case would at the heart of
the case would be
ah issue concerning uh
quantum physics quantum mechanics uh the
uncertainty of the world
the the the way in which what that which
we look at
changes uh by are looking and they hold
the idea of superpositions and
and various things like that and at the
same time i wanted to write the story in
such a way that the story itself
uh was symbolic of the quantum universe
um or at least the way in which
things act uh as far as we know on on
that level
and i was just fascinated by this
abstruse this obscure
this this this challenge this this
difficult
um problem um and it was that more than
anything
but also i think the thing that
fascinated me was it was the
relationship between writing itself
and the quantum world i i find there's a
great
um resonance between between between the
two things so
um you have to understand you know uh
florian that you know
um as a child the first
one one of the first things i wanted to
be was a scientist i want to be a
physicist
if i'd known when i was a kid that there
was such a thing as speculative physics
i i you wouldn't be talking to me now
i'll be i'll be where you are
where you are
that's that's wonderful uh it's
interesting because i had the opposite
things i was um doing theater before and
then switch midway to become unscientist
so maybe that
that's what we are we are just opposites
i mean we switch
at the same time um i have another
question for you
um you you use real places to anchor
your story um
and um we we talked about when when i i
propose you to read the story you're
like oh it would be great to have some
way to like
not have the audience just watch me read
and i was like what can i do and
i started looking at maps of london and
i starting to see that i could actually
pinpoint
all the details like all the places that
you mentioned in the book the bookshop
the channel
the the police station uh all the
streets are real and
exist and like can you tell us why you
picked like a real place is it because
you were worried that if you have
an uh like a a weird location plus
quantum physics that would be too much
for the reader
or you were like oh this is the place
that i like that i know and i can create
something that's
um that can have multiple uh varieties
on this
um all of the above actually plus um
plus the one of the um
one of the great i think one of the
great um secret laws of
of writing uh which is that um
the um the real is underpinned by the
unreal and the unreal is supported by
the real
um these two things kind of work uh uh
together invisibly
in just the same way that the quantum
world and what we perceive of as
the world of certainties operate at the
same time one is concealed
or as it were exists deep inside inside
the other so
one needs the reality you i i find that
to investigate on reality you need you
need reality
to really look deeply into a problem the
more truthful the place is the more
real the place is the easier it is for
you to actually plunge
into into into your exploration
yep that's wonderful i'm going to start
um reading through the the question that
the audience is putting on the the q a
panel um we have a first question
which is uh maybe more common than a
question from michelle dobre who's one
of the quantum physicists that we have
at yqi he says a fantasy
fantastic quantum story and something is
puzzling him uh is the story built
around the picture of a frogman
in the canal or is it the opposite and
the reason why i'm i'm putting this is
because
it's a funny comments that michelle is
really well known that to name
all of these quantum objects
uh animals so we we had of course the
cats um but there's
um a snail happening there's also uh
some squids
and so i wouldn't be worried i wouldn't
be surprised that in the near future
one of the quantum devices had a frog
somehow linked into this uh
youtube video i will keep an eye on on
that and i'll let you know and maybe you
can you should take some of the credits
uh if we see a [ __ ] computer
with a frog system we have another um we
have another question
um from somebody that you uh probably
know uh priya natarajan who's the
director of the frankie program
and she said um i love the layers of
reality that you explore in this story
just curious do you believe that
narratives are stable
or are you playing with this notion as
well
yeah all wonderful questions um
again uh narrative like
like uh the relationship between reality
and the quantum world
narrative while you're reading it the
arc of it
widely immersed in it and reading the
words and following the story
and the characters and the plot appear
stable um
when you when you've finished reading it
and you've left the text
the inherited instability narrative
then begins to act on memory mind
emotion
nostalgia replay and all of that then
you go back to the text again
and then something strange happens um
what was fixed and familiar
and uh certain and definite uh undergoes
occasionally wobbles and and and and and
wrinkles
um it changes um
yeah you finish it again with this new
changing and you you go back and
live your life and you come back to the
text again and the same thing has
happened
so is narrative stable is it unstable
it's very very impossible to say it's
it's a it's the same
this is what this is what i'm trying to
say that the literature that writing
shares something of the quantum universe
it really really does
um because when you have it in front of
you
you you do you take a famous line that
like to be or not to be you have it in
front of you
it is absolutely fixed just like this
this chair or this table that i'm
looking at um
uh but you you come back to it you you
break it down you you
you look into it you move away from it
you carry it around in your spirit you
come back to it another time
and something about it has shifted
something about it is altered
um and i think narrative plays and works
with our consciousness in the same way
that the reality of reality works and
warps and changes and shapes with with
our consciousness
i think the two things are linked i
didn't choose the quantum
universe arbitrarily in the writing of
this story it's also meant to be a
parallel
of the way in which literature the way
in which words
um letters um punctuation
um these little quantum tools as it were
work um on on on on the mind and on
consciousness
thank you very much um another question
i have
is that um prayer for the living your
new book
uh is a very political book um like the
in the oh yeah you have the the new
version even better here we go
um i will put in the chat um so i think
you will have
in the invitation from zoom you have the
link if you wish if you wish to uh to
buy the book you should be able to do it
through uh different
uh online sellers so feel free to um to
grab
a copy they all the stories are really
wonderful and are high we highly
recommend this book it's pretty good
um and and so in
uh it's it seems to be the less uh
subversive than
for example if we can run the first
story uh boko haram
about a suicide bomber child and and
still in this murder mystery which
seems very political you have you
explore some racial tension
in the policy departments between uh the
deeply draper and the superintendent
and it's a it's a very shocking thing
because um there's been a lot of
discussion about
race and racial prejudices and and
systematic racism
and even this story when you when the
the reader is focusing on the the loops
and like
all the clues and all the details you
bring them back in into reality and
realize that even if this
in this alternate reality is you have
the same the same flow and prejudices
it's i find it like an incredibly
effective uh
tool like narrative tool to like really
bring back like
is it something that um you you thought
uh in advance like oh this is a way or
did you
decay more organically say like because
this is uh
this is what usually uh happens in this
kind of uh
structure yes well
but it came organically because um um
you know i wanted i wanted you first of
all to follow this detective
um purely uh from a point of view
of of of the tradition um
traditional detectives like sherlock
holmes like lupine has
suddenly become famous now because of
the netflix series i want you to follow
first of all enter into a genre
identification
with with detective draper
and to enter enter this world enter
the exploration with him just purely on
that basis
um on the on the pleasure of that of
that tradition
um but at some point i wanted to
pull the reader up short with the
unstated reality i
i'm fascinated by unstated realities um
in
in in reading because because i think um
we're over we're overwhelmed by stated
realities and after a point
we stop seeing them we stop noticing
the the the depth of certain problems
the depth of certain realities
we stop noticing them because we we we
we we acquire kind of object blindness
from too much familiarity and too much
ease and too much
um superficial
saturation in a sense and i wanted to
drain the story of all of that
and for you to experience that fact
which was there all along
towards the end of the story or or in
the middle of it just to
just to sprinkle it and then come back
out because i think sometimes when you
invert things
they they they are they are they're
they're stronger
um it's it's just it's just it's just a
new way of dealing with
one of the one of the facts of of of uh
of of a rich universe
thank you very much um thank you it's a
lovely
lovely lovely tough question yeah i know
um we have some more question in in the
chat uh somebody said that um
i was curious about the reference to the
bus explosion and the murderer put
potentially being a terrorist
are there a social political intent
in introducing these elements in light
of the story being written through the
eyes of the police of a police officer
trying to make sense of an ambiguous
events unfolding in the london elder
class
yes um absolutely i wanted these
uh political realities to to to to be
there within
what seems to be a genre of fiction
that is complicated by by
by by quantum mechanics um i i love the
idea of having these
these realities they're also in london
where i live um
you know
of cancer rise i just you know there's
been a lot of those kind of tensions
there
and um i mean i mean the story the story
has um uh to to use the gardeners terms
healthy roots the root is through rooted
in
in in in in real things that have given
um a more mysterious expression
so i wanted to be true to a reality that
i knew
um even while writing this
what seems like a piece of genre of
fiction
thank you i i like i like i like invaded
reality i like i like creating worlds
where they're real
whether the realities of of the world in
which we're living in
invades it and seeps into it um
as well as doing the opposite which is
looking head-on as you said with the
book of haram stories i like i like you
looking head-on at things in a in a very
steady intense way but i also also like
the indirect
leaking in wow
i have another question more general
about the book um it's a collection of
short story that i know
you've collected through all your career
uh sorry yeah
i i like it i like it we have to we have
to keep alternating
it's an alternate realities i have
something also speaking of alternate
realities i had a question because this
uh in the lecture the the chapter the
part five
is missing and so i was wondering if it
was like
in my head i was like oh maybe it's like
a chapter somewhere like but it's hidden
somewhere in the book
and i just realized when you read it i
had this like realization at the same
time that uh inspector draper
like was unraveling the mystery i was
like oh i'm unwriting the mystery of my
copy
uh it's just
uh so yeah in this collection of series
um how did you peek in
and arrange the order and i i know that
uh short story i consider
uh the hardest form of literature to
write
um for you what was the advantage of
using these formats
you mean the short story format or the
way in which it was arranged oh i mean
yeah yeah but why uh why did you pick uh
to do a collection of short stories uh
and
instead of maybe you could have expanded
some of the some of the other
story that you had into like a
full-fledged novel like what
what is the advantage of having this
this format oh florian florian
the whole point of uh of the truth of a
short story
a lot of a lot of writers well a lot of
writers tend to think that um you know
you yeah that this that this short story
um is
is really a frustrated short novel um
or rather a stunted uh a novel or a
novel that just didn't get a chance to
that grow hadn't hadn't had its vitamins
and it's and it's uh
and it's protein um no that's that's not
the case that's not the case at all
um if a short story can be expanded to a
novel
then it never was a short story in the
first place um
it's just that you didn't realize it and
we we have to remember that
people like joyce uh ulysses was what
was was meant to be the
one one of the last short stories in
in in in in dubliners um and it's just
just it's just it just grew and
it was never a short story um you know
you can't expand
a short story uh into a novel um
that's that's that's that's that's the
that's that's the nature of this short
story um
it is completely it has it has it has a
complete integrity
of his of his compactness uh the
complete integrity of its um
of the fact that it cannot be made more
than it is
it is its perfect and complete length
and it's not really about the length
it is about the tensions uh contained
within it it's about
actually forgive the phrase florian it
really is about this quantum
it's it's it's it's quantum universe the
inner space is the
the the the core that the electrons the
things working inside it the the the
way they work and play with one another
in a tremendously secret
inner world dynamism um it's the the
short story is is is is is really a
world it's not a compressed world it's
it's it's a complete world um um
you might just take us it might appear
that you've taken a slice of it
but the laws that make it uh are
are complete and i i love this short
story form as a
it's for me it's one of the best forms
to to to explore
um uh certain thought
uh experiments certain questions certain
challenges certain themes
uh certain obsessions um it's it's it's
it's more than a laser it's it's it's a
laser it's nice modern laser more than
an x-ray
it's it's a it's a it's it's a new kind
of um
a very high powered um
super lens that looks really deep
into the the the the nature of a problem
and yet is able to distill it
um into into this it's it's a i think
it's a miraculous
i think it's a miraculous form and
that's that's that's why
um i've done so few of them because they
take such a long time to
to to to craft um and and to
so that they have this extraordinary uh
strange living
tension
thank you very much um well maybe we can
take
one uh last question um and then
be generous florin oh okay we'll see so
uh you've heard then if you have more
questions feel free to uh
yeah take two take take two or three
more
we'll do um so um we have someone who uh
who's writing that
um thank you i was uh fascinated by your
work
and i am currently writing my bachelor
dissertation on the
famish roads and uh unjockey this novel
transparent city
i am wondering if you know of the
concept of ubuntu
and if you think that it that this or
commonly in general
is one of the steps that leads to a
better world or do you think that
urbanization
global globalization and capitalism have
a negative impact on communities
at least the small one such as the
compound and then abstract potential
growth and experiences
oh my goodness that question is as far
from the quantum universe
but then at the same time but then at
the same time it isn't because it's
i mean ubuntu is ubuntu is uh um
is is in in how um
the philosophy of uh uh a quantum
universe
um affects and shapes her whole world um
yeah i think i think ubuntu is a very
great african concept that can have very
great
important consequences uh um for the
world it's
um uh it's a philosophy that that should
be that should be made
more more widely known um
it's a philosophy of of of compassion of
um
[Music]
uh of of community
um of of harmony um
and uh yeah i i i love the sound of it
and uh what was the question about
globalization has it had an impact on
on communities and yes on especially the
smaller ones if you want um you can also
open the panel
uh it's a long question and so you
should be able to see it it's the first
one on the top
yeah i'm going to i'm not going to get
drawn into that that would be too
complicated for me
to to to get into the whole yeah
um to give a very short answer uh yes
globalization has had a negative impact
um on on smaller communities
um it's it's uh one of the
um one of the difficult things uh
to to to deal with um how to
how to keep the richness of small
communities um
within the impact of of of of
globalization
and yet at the same time you know uh
globalization is
one of the one of the facts um of
of of our world um and i'm a great
believer in not wishing away
a fact the fact is something we have to
deal with
negotiate uh fight neutralize
work with uh do something about but we
have to
we have to face them um it's what we
writers do we
we're not good at running away from
facts we we look at them
and give them give them an an image
um and the impact of globalization can
be seen and
quite quite a few of the stories um in
in in this collection
thank you um on on that topic of uh
of african beliefs we have another
question of like
uh how do the average um the african uh
spiritual beliefs
with the fruitity between the natural
world and the spiritual realm influence
the story
or do they
i'm not sure that they do except to the
degree that
maybe my mind is already you know
saturated with
um certain um beliefs that i
grew up with um in in nigeria
um there's not just a belief but this
sense that you know the
uh the boundaries between realms is more
fluid than
them than we think maybe that already
predisposed me to be
interested in in the in the quantum
in the quantum universe where the
you know the invasion uh where
where suddenly reality is is is for the
for the for the first time in a
scientific context
on the on the under on the great great
doubt and great great scooting
great uh uh uncertainty um
you know the the other thing i want to
add quite separate from that um florian
um about about my fascination with with
quantum mechanics is um
is the place of consciousness in in all
of this and of course this is something
that you know
um quantum physicists are not
i don't know how you deal with you deal
with it you you
you deal with the external aspect of the
effect of measurement
the the the the the the effect of
measurement on
on on or the effect of looking of
witnessing of observing
on the uh actual process the the
the split experiments uh for example
but i am fascinated in what it is
about consciousness
about the conscious the fact of the
consciousness of the observer
that actually gives rise to this effect
that actually gives rise to the fixing
of of of of of these
um subparticles into either wave
uh or a particle i'm fascinated by
this side of the of of the quantum
equation
us and our consciousness and how it
it what what is going on here
that affects what's going on if you can
say
there um and is this can i can i can i
ask you is this something that is
dealt with at all within the within
within within within the quantum
institute is this something you guys
look at so it's it's uh
it's something like the observer effect
is something that of course
is uh is really uh well known here and
then
that's uh they they they try to fight
but i don't think there's a there's a
more um
like there's a more philosophical uh
research of that
like in the world because in the
day-to-day life of a researcher
they they perform they perform
experiments and
uh and the way they deal with this
observer effect is that they use
uh side techniques to like measure
indirectly
uh the the the measurements and and the
and perform calculation
in in an indirect way to avoid to
perturb the uh the result and the
the inside of the experiments and so i i
don't think people are
really thinking about how themselves
affect the results i think they they
more are looking for ways to
uh to prevent that from happening and
obtaining the
the right answer however that's
something that the the yellow quantum
institute uh has been trying to
to investigate by hiring artists in
residence
we had a few people uh coming in
and trying to think about these these
topics
and uh that's something that's uh i
don't think
researcher like who are trying to build
quantum computer currently
uh have time to think about that there's
a huge race in in the us and the world
to build the first quantum computers and
i think
it's gonna it's gonna be another pan of
the of research
or of maybe having people from the
humanities and
and philosophy trying to think about
these these topics and and i think
bringing in
artists um that that might be able to
use
a different technique or different
medium to sort of open a reflection
uh is something that that we've done for
example in the in this space
um but that's in front of me we used to
have a big
a big quantum computer like it was an
art piece
done by martha lewis that had uh cameras
and sensor and when the
when the the visitor will go inside this
installation
uh it the visitor was perturbing the
calculation that was done on with lights
and
and sensor and so it was it was
interesting to see that
um the the art piece was working
perfectly performing a very simple
quantum
uh computation but it was working
without anybody in it and as soon as
a visitor enters the space the camera
will pick it up and then we'll sort of
like disturb the
the calculation and you couldn't really
do uh the calculation anymore
and so there was a way to see how
ourselves
are like disturbing the the quantum
world in a sense um so of course
everything was
everything was that quantum because
there was at the scale at the human
scale and
it was doing in in classical computers
but there was we were trying to
to start um to to to create this uh this
tiny idea in the people's head
to to start thinking about these these
topics
interesting we have to have more of
these conversations
i think i think i think i think science
i think science i think science needs to
uh take an interest
we need to be at some point in the
future we're going to have to deal with
the science of consciousness
at some point we may be in uh it may be
in a thousand years time but we're going
to have to deal with it
and and if it's a shorter time frame
than that maybe that would be a good
excuse to have you come to
the yqa but if it's a thousand years
well
we'll have to wait for that i might i
might still be around who knows
decompose time slow time down that's
right
and any other any other questions before
i go uh let me have a quick look
um in the chat uh yes we have one last
question
um which is on the topic of short story
uh who do you admire admire as master of
the art form
past or present is there any modern day
uh practitioner that
excites you on this so it's a more
general um on the
on the theme of short story oh my
goodness
um i guess i love what they want is like
maybe some recommendation
some good read recommendation on short
story
[Laughter]
yeah i'm very i'm really i'm kind of
very i'm very old i'm very old-fashioned
and um
i mean i read a lot of new short stories
but i go back to
i go back to the old ones for um for the
reasons i i mentioned
um i mentioned earlier because the the
thing about um
the thing about a great short story you
think about a great novel the thing
about a great poem a great piece of
writing
um is that it it multiplies
its realities it really does
it's it's not only is it not the same
every time you read it
it gets incredibly richer it gets
immeasurably richer
and i think we bring that constant
richness to it
but in order for that to happen there is
one condition for that to happen
which is that the peace itself has to
um have acquired uh have been i've
had to have begun first of all with the
condition of a very high level
of of of achievement of accomplishment
of compression of truth
of integrity call it greatness call it
whatever you want it has to have had
that
first and then that has to have
interacted and moved and played and
danced and
shaped and shaped shape in time itself
and consciousness and many readers and
so a text is enriched
by the vast number of secret readings
brought
and so i i tend to go back to the um um
reading enriched uh text texts that have
played and worked and dreamt through
time so i love some of the
some of the cervantes short stories um
and here's another very interesting one
donkey show to a book that's almost a
thousand pages long
it began as a short story that tells you
something
about the way in which the short can
contain
uh the vast um and the vast can contain
the
small um i check over i keep i keep
i keep going back to um
you know the many wonderful um modern
masters
and many of them can be read in the
pages of the new york and magazines and
anthologies um around the world there
many young excellent um
african writers um it's it's not hard to
find
really really good short stories but if
you want if you want to deep
deep travel and a deep journey um well
go to the ones that have um acquired
their presence in
time
good good to people like czecho yes more
personal
yeah thank you so much ben uh maybe
we can conclude on that by doing some
entanglement experiments when i can show
the uk version of your book
and you can show us the us version of
your book uh
the um so uh yes uh
the link to buy the book is uh somewhere
in the chat you should be able to find
it
um thank you so much for the time uh
that you have to read this wonderful
short story
uh thank you for answering all your
questions and thank you all
thank you all very much i kept you know
it's been a real pleasure
um i hope we meet in the flesh someday
and look after yourself
that would be a great pleasure thank you
very much ben have a good night
florian florian thank you hope we meet
soon
take care